[Music]
ah you're [__] Google sis a Lazaro
[__] my birthday's coming up soon
December 17th December 17
[Music]
there you go [__] weep you tears
1,000 tons before you [__] MOOC the
MOOC uncle Joey here Monday night with
my family of Goomba Lisa a tremendous
album the [__] doors la woman from
the big band [__] Texas beat to hell
a woman will wrap them and [__]
rolling tonight as usual
oh you came on a good night alright war
[__] plus plus look at this one from
the old school that back
two hundred and forty [__] milligrams
plus we're going deeper than deep TKO
[__]
TKO [__] and one more DK up don't you
love her don't you love her as he's
walking off your door oh who the [__]
you think you did with [__] this
Monday night I missed you I missed you
[Music]
you bad [__]
who gives a [__] my wife she takes
everything literally they caused the
fire down the block to see their little
fire departments now that I call up it
she went and [__] went through emails
squad is broken who gives a [__] I don't
live there burn the whole burn the whole
[__] not our house don't worry the
[__] house on the corner there next
to the two transgenders Manny and Fanny
oh [__]
you bad [__] I can smell the
tea you ever smell the TAC don't you
love them badly
don't you love our badly you forget that
water we can't you can't you wait till
this comes to your [__] head would
look at this oh Jesus Christ
model Nami look at this BAM Brown it's a
great oh don't don't
goddamn blow
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna be smiling gum delicious
nutritious and part of your primal
filled diet
yeah the salmon just drink the [__]
thing we we don't [__] around here
Monday night sister we listen the only
way to get the rest of the week going is
by Monday I've been telling you about
for years [__] warden warden oh
[__]
you're lucky people think your feeling
was on a Monday huh this sets the tone
for the [__] week to have a good
Friday you gotta have a good Monday okay
you heard that from uncle Joey leave
these little packages you put this in
your microwave oven for breakfast and
you're smearing on your toast
who's gonna [__] stop you huh hey
who's gonna [__] stop you [__]
nobody we get it together yo whatever
eager to take this [__] it's just
chocolate [__]
what are you gonna do on Easter we not
doing the Easter with your kids too
shitty they want to eat chocolate over
that gag in his [__]
[__] people no decency no decency
[__] the Donalds changing you got
a new president [__]
president-elect whatever the [__] you
want to call him I don't give a [__]
he's the president I come from it's a
[__] thing January 20th big deal we
went to another bunny are you gonna sit
there like a [__] move
oh [__] babe let's fill up another bun
wait you gonna sit there for we arms
cross [__] Lee wants a bun he's
sitting over there foaming from the
mountain saying Jesus Christ joy you're
a [__] gavone i'm over here eating to
please the chocolate nobody gives me a
[__] bomb that's right read his mind
how do you have the cause of death then
I read his mother deep in the murky
waters that one there oh yeah that's
them that's the one there you go you got
momentum there you go it's over it's
over it's over it's always training
[__]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
listen if you're gonna go deep go deep
like Pedro Bob oh whatever it's [__]
name is Escobar that's the lesson I
learned from narco Zak if you're gonna
sell coke demise will blow up things do
this [__] you're in the same
neighborhood it's time for butter
packages now it's over we didn't what
what do you mean what we did with the
one in what set the [__] presidents a
new president and we're kind of and
we're trying to set a precedent you
understand me yeah we ain't [__]
around we gotta send the message out to
you [__] no way I'm [__]
around them alright you wanna [__]
around go hang out with some other
podcast ISM they were so insightful
we ain't insightful I got nothing for
you I got nothing for you but we flow
heart and more heart and if you can't
deal with that switch the channel
[__] it's gonna be alright Lee
BAM the power of Christ compels you oh
yeah oh yeah boom I'm like a [__] THC
magician you understand me one minute
you see it one minute it's gone and if
you're 18 hang up now [__] I
don't want the butler bother me tomorrow
Oh German this delicious nutritious and
it goes right the heart and you sleep
like a [__] baby the mom on the oven
tonight we go home lastly I got a better
one you won't see me to [__] lurk
until 7:00 with things in my eyes and I
got not only a bad breath you got bad
nose hair bad nose [__] breath
anything you sniffs it's like ten
[__] fun what do we do another one
here well you can't walk on one leg
little boys and girls always remember
that you got to do the one extra
and if they're expired don't [__] with
him cuz dam is stronger than one
anticipated I had a great day today
good things happen grow up my goals for
the week walk my goals for the last
[__] six weeks worked on the book
least wine over they in saying much he
knows he's going to the next [__]
frontier at all two different types of
THC look at this one here this is GUI
Louie and chewy oh look at oh god that
tastes like [__] battery or but you
know what it does the job he gave me
extra you need extra and that's it and
that's that there's no explosives
there's no political humor you know
intriguing mind conversations [__] you
you know what you got here the uncle
Joey
nice and simple you let me know what you
need and we try to hook you up if not
take a [__] hike [__] did you
say bomb hit I thought that's what you
said that's interesting I was thinking
bonding maybe we're connected ESP it
[__] you know I'm saying we got drool on
your shirt oh yeah chocolate drool get
that thing off your [__] I wanted on
camera people don't embarrass me if they
see choc with drool on his shirt you
believe this show I got over four years
of Ecology we have nice time in Boston
if you came to the world but I love you
if they came to Foxwoods they [__]
love you tremendous and you
[__] who brought you two moms
two people brought their moms I love you
even more we'll talk during the podcast
that's it we're sitting me and listen to
one of the greatest sound was the doors
put out L a woman some great [__]
songs
listen I don't know if Snoop Dogg I
don't know be money I don't know Bri
don't know nobody
I don't know this is at least I ain't
knows me and I know you and you know me
I would sure you would mean and there
will I see understand me so [__] them
all
[__] them in here [__] them any other
year anyway
it's that time to stretch up if you're
under 18 I said that already I got them
you know kind of remind these
[__] if you're on 18 hang up
now
you like the suntan I live I did four I
worked out tonight jump rope and I flip
him to kettlebells in the backyard I
[__] just do sets I got a jump rope
of weights at the end that [__] jump
rope for 30 seconds I'll jump rope in
2002 I trip up the first five times I'm
just breathing you know I'm dying and
I'll switch it up the squats with the
kettlebell the right the tool cleans and
define sets of swings I just push ups I
did sit-ups I had nice little [__]
sweat and it's nice you outside you get
some [__] vitamin B you know it was
too nice to be inside today so sometimes
you got to make the exception as long as
you make do the same thing that you're
gonna do out break the heart up a little
bit give it some a nice stretch really
well I did some real attack but that
besides it oh [__]
that playing my jam [__] it must be
time to do a bomb hit somewhere it's
4/20 for you [__] anyway yeah the Sun
felt very nice today on your face feels
nice on your face I'm saying
[Music]
my [__] around when I stick it to the
next level oh [__] oh [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'd call from perennial [__] go get
some what's the street Ventura and
Koufax took a look around see which way
the wind blow with a little girl and a
Hollywood bungalow are you [__]
kidding me
[Music]
or just another lost angel sitting there
are you [__] kidding me but you got
heroin doing that position good as it
[__] gets jesus [__] christ
whoa come on
[Applause]
[Music]
we took you [__] away you think I'm
gonna show up here like these regular
[__] Gentiles Starbucks coffee and
tell your story they know stories do the
bomb gets dead you tell me the [__]
stories all right la woman oh [__]
let's get goodness [__] right
now we might have to set the block on
fire that day when I was a kid I was a
pyromaniac oh [__] a real Jew fire
listen it was like some white fight the
Jews light up a fire it's over by the
time you get there the dog is on fire
when the Jewish your outside fights all
over those Israeli Jews oh my god by the
time you're dialing 9-1-1 three quarters
is good they're trained in that [__] we
do there we go
our senior hair is burning
oh [__]
some beautiful night isn't it
we're here with family Guerrero didn't
come for the show is burning hills are
filled with fire if they said I never
loved you
[Music]
there you go there you go like a soldier
look at that tremendous look at that
he ain't [__] around no more we ain't
no little point he's grown up into a
savage never saw a woman
[Music]
so one
may I kill the rest of this weed on the
trick you know how we do it
[Applause]
[Music]
Motel money but a madness take your moon
from set the gladness
[Applause]
[Music]
speaking of Parkman yes come and look at
this [__] studio hey open the door
let the [__] I got a kick out the jams
brothers and sisters
[Music]
back we had open up the door and let the
bad spirit I don't say it was some bad
spirits left in here from those deers
demo smart ghost anyway
this Friday night Houston Texas to come
and take it festival ten o'clock we get
your tickets come and take it calm
what's up come and take it at gmail.com
that's not like that 2016
h-town [__] papacito's Chuy's will go
and eat Kalaa cheese Malati's the
mawashi brothers then the following
Wednesday before Thanksgiving
Irvine California be they'll be square
and a clock show mr. mojo risin are you
[__] kidding me
are you [__] kidding me pound pound
pound pound [__] tremendous that's why
he was just Morrison concept
[Applause]
I got equality Bravo cos if this is CIA
music they did a good job club anyway
good to see you [__] you know
when I'm on the road now this last
flight is sadly leeteuk were busy I have
no time to be smoking joints on the
streets and I had a balcony but to have
a say which way the wind blow anyway you
bad [__] you have a great
podcast Wednesday night we got a great
podcast tonight but most importantly
you're gonna have to weaken your [__]
lives you understand [__] will the
president is it's all about you and what
you got your [__] nut sack anyway or
your [__] sack whatever the [__] you're
gonna get out there do some stop your
[__] stop and comes up this he's the
present what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do he's gonna cry get the [__]
out there live your life grab that
[__] clip and go smack a [__] at her
face like an elephant I'm saying Joel
Osteen
[Applause]
la Warr ma oh [__] I'm not stoned quick
I'm right through the bloodstream I like
it this week for this hardcore you know
I tell you [__] hey woman
uh-huh oh [__] monday might be one of
those playing on the left football
Bengals and Giants it don't even matter
to me I don't even care if if I don't
wait a would I can't watch this [__]
what do you do it I'm saying
what time you got Lisa 752 your mother
where's brick [__] shoes you know I'm
saying I love you [__]
like I said come and take your festival
Friday Houston Texas Dallas you better
drive up [__] Corpus Christi you
better drive up cuz this is it for me in
Texas this year I ain't going to Austin
for a long [__] time so get your [__]
together I love you guys stay tuned
youtube.com slash mad flavor see slash
Joey B is there you go
get it together I'll see you guys in ten
minutes stay black